salut à tous c'est Christophe pour la
chronique politique et oui ça faisait
longtemps
et aujourd'hui je voulais faire une
vidéo pour réagir à l'actualité autour
de la manifestation qui a eu lieu le 25
mars dernier à Sainte-Soline contre la
méga bassine en construction
comme tout le monde j'ai pu assister au
discours victimaire dans les médias des
écolos et notamment des élus Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui nous expliquait
que cette manif était totalement
pacifiste et que la police avait enfin
les CRS avait de façon injustifiée
utilisée une violence totalement
disproportionnée et donc cette vidéo
pour voir si bien effectivement les
manifestants étaient gentils et
pacifiques et si la police a dérapé ou
si bien cette violence qui s'est
exprimée a été volontaire ou même
organisé par une minorité des
manifestants
alors tout d'abord une parenthèse sur
les méga bassines ce sont des structures
qui sont actuellement à la mode qui sont
créés pour stocker de l'eau issue des
nappes phréatiques qui sont pompés en
hiver quand elles se recharge et que de
fait qu'il y a un trop d'eau qui qui
ensuite va s'écouler dans les rivières
et dans la mer donc pour s'en créer pour
en fin de compte garder ce trodo qui est
issu des nappes phréatiques
alors les opposants disent que du coup
ça nuit au rechargement de snapréatiques
certaines études en tout cas dans le
régions dans la région poitvine nous
disent que au vu des bassines déjà
construites enfin ça permet plutôt au
contraire de préserver une partie des
nappes phréatiques pendant la période de
sécheresse
il est probable qu'en fin de compte
selon les régions selon les zones et
bien certaines de ces signes sont utiles
et d'autres comme toute infrastructure
en fin de compte ce qu'on va l'étudier
mal calibré pour la région et son
potentiellement nuisibles mais
a priori il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir
un dogme figé soit pro ou antibacine
comme le font nos écolos
également une remarque certains à droite
notamment dans le magazine Le Point
nous disent que qui sont très en pointe
contre dans la lutte contre les
croyances écolos effectivement sont
souvent des croyances erronées donc au
point nous explique que le GIEC
recommande c'est méga bassines pour
lutter contre la sécheresse alors je
vais vous mettre le seul et unique
extrait du rapport du GIEC qui qui parle
de ces mégas bassines
chacun sera son opinion mais enfin c'est
quand même beaucoup moins clair que ce
que nous dit le point grosso modo le
terme water serage apparaît cité avec
plein d'autres méthodes qui sont de fait
déjà utilisées aujourd'hui contre la
sécheresse et c'est plus un constat à
mon avis de la part du GIEC qui est un
encouragement à utiliser ces méthodes
il y a pas de prise de position je pense
claire dans le texte du Gex sur ces
questions donc en tout cas depuis
quelques temps c'est méga bassines sont
la nouvelle lubie j'ai envie de dire des
écolos après les OGM après glyphosate
on a donc la lutte contre sébacine et
qui cristallise notamment autour de
celle de Soline maintenant concernant
cette manif les méga bassines semblent
devenir le nouveau notre pierre
d'achoppement nouveau point de
cristallisation du mouvement écolo après
différentes fixettes comme le glyphosate
ou les OGM dans les années et les
décennies passées
première chose qu'on peut noter sur
cette manif c'est le discours quand même
assez
lénifiant de des manifestants qui
globalement ont quand même un niveau
d'argumentation assez faible qui nous
explique que l'eau c'est fait pour être
stockée dans le sol parce qu'elle les
plantes et ce genre de choses donc on
est sur un niveau on n'est pas sur des
météorologues ou des géologues un très
clairement comme souvent avec les
argumentaires écolos sur ce genre de
questions techniques on est quand même
sur du niveau très très bas et on sent
qu'on a des gens qui sont là plus parce
que ça va contre leur moral que sur les
arguments techniques
on va voir quelques quelques extraits
qui sont assez significatifs vous allez
voir c'est un petit peu les méchant
pourquoi on vient là se prendre
des lacs
accaparement de l'eau par 5 % des
agriculteurs l'eau qui va manquer dans
quelques années cruellement mais c'est
pas grave on continue à subventionner ça
réellement n'importe quoi alors que
l'eau elle est bien à sa place sous le
sol il y a pas besoin de la sortir c'est
une furdité écologique l'eau si on veut
la stocker il faut la laisser dans le
sol il faut un moratoire il faut se
rassembler autour de ces problèmes et il
faut surtout arrêter les travaux des
bassines il faut les il faut les stopper
on est un refuse de comprendre que c'est
méga bassines c'est complètement
incohérentes niveau écologique et même
sociétal c'est n'importe quoi enfin on
nous prend pour des cons en fait le
peuple ne sait pas il y a que les élus
qui savent en tout cas argument les
nifiant pas de fait cette magnifique
lieu et maintenant on va voir si c'est
violentes ont été organisées plus ou
moins volontairement par les
manifestants ou sont dues aux méthodes
de maintien de l'ordre
lorsqu'il faut savoir sur cette manif
c'est qu'en fait dès le début elle a été
programmée pour être divisée en trois
cortèges distincts avec
des noms de code notamment un cortège
qui s'appelait les loutres jaunes et
selon les journalistes sur place et
d'ailleurs y compris des journalistes
militants de gauche vous aviez notamment
le youtubeur partagé c'est sympa qui est
toujours très proche de la France
insoumise et qui est toujours sur les
questions écolo
quand on regarde les images qu'on a de
ce cortège on voit clairement que voilà
que c'est pas typé loutre jaune c'est
plutôt typé Black Bloc quoi tout le
monde est équipé pour faire face à des
gaz à lacrymogènes à des masques des
lunettes
portent des couleurs sombres et par
contre à côté vous avez d'autres
cortèges qui sont plus plus classiques
de manifs avec des drapeaux syndicaux de
la musique ce genre de choses
et quand on regarde les vidéos on voit
clairement que ce fameux cortège des
loutres jaunes dès le début vous en
découdre au-delà de l'équipement quand
même assez caractéristique de ceux qui
participent on a notamment des slogans
comme nous aussi on va passer en force
qui sont scandés largement avant
d'arriver au contact des CRS donc des
gens qui avaient clairement en tête
quelque chose avant même que les
lacrymoparts
et ce qui est
ce qui est manifeste enfin ce qui est
très probable c'est qu'en fin de compte
c'est trois cortèges étaient là
clairement pour saturer les CRS pouvoir
entourer la zone et les déborder et il
est probable que dans ce dispositif les
loutres jaunes étaient un petit peu le
fer de lance violent qui devait ensuite
qu'il devait saturer les CRS
potentiellement créer une brèche et
ensuite permettre aux autres
manifestants non violents et qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les loutres jaunes de
pouvoir ensuite entrer dans dans la zone
de construction de la bassine et
l'occuper alors était est-ce que
l'occupation souhaitait était temporaire
ou plus définitive genre une sorte de
ZAD bonne question mais il est il est
clair quand on voit les images et la
répartition des cortèges que il y avait
une répartition des rôles entre des
manifestants qui étaient gentils
pacifistes qui faisait de la musique qui
était là pour faire des images
sympa des manifestants et de l'autre
côté des groupes beaucoup plus
déterminés qui étaient là pour assurer
le côté violent et potentiellement la
réussite de la manifestation qui devait
solder par l'occupation de la bassine
d'ailleurs quand on regarde quand on
écoute les gens qui participaient à ces
manifs on a un tout autre discours que
le discours victimaire que nous jouent
les écolos sur sur les grands médias
très clairement vous avez une bonne
partie qui
cautionne ces violences même quand on
regarde le reportage de partager ces
sympas enfin le gars participe en soi la
manif il est pas là pour pour manifester
juste autour des CRS on sent bien qu'il
est là pour passer en force et
occuper le truc donc on est quand même
sur un double discours on est là pour
manifester gentiment mais bon
si jamais les loutres jaunes comme par
hasard elle pouvait réussir à créer une
brèche un cordon de CRS bon
ça plairait quand même à tout le monde
ok début de la deuxième journée de
mobilisation c'est le temps fort il y a
trois groupes qui
partent le compteur ne cesse d'augmenter
parce que les gens arrivent de partout
on serait maintenant 25000 personnes
l'énergie la différence là c'est un mode
d'action qui est un peu en mode d'action
du dernier recours face à face à un
modèle qui est sourd et aveugle quoi
retourner vers le pont il y a une autre
action de son potage très sympa à faire
ne vous inquiétez pas la lutte n'est pas
finie qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'action violente pour entrer sur cette
bassine en face de nous donc on voit
bien que faction pacifiste qui était
celle qui était promue par le mouvement
elle peut pas être respectée puisqu'on
est pas respecté dans nos droits
malheureusement
il y a des individus qui passent le le
cap
[Musique]
quelque part l'agacement de certaines
personnes quoi les gens comprennent pas
qu'on défendent la vie et eux ils
défendent la mort autre élément on a
aussi le l'organisateur principal de
cette mouvance antibacine Julien Legay
qui d'ailleurs est interdit était
interdit à cette manif et qui s'est
quand même retrouvé
bref
donc Julien Leguet qui quelques jours
avant cette manif expliqué dans une
interview à France 3 que actuellement
dans la région il y avait une virgule 5
bassine en construction et que
potentiellement dans quelques jours donc
après la manif il y en aurait plus que
0,5
donc on a la quand même clairement
l'initiateur de tout mouvement qui est
en train de nous expliquer que ben oui
là peut-être qu'après notre manif voilà
il y aura une bassine en moins en
construction
chacun interprétera ses propos comme il
veut mais enfin
quand même ça laisse sous-entendre pas
mal de choses
donc voilà on a en fin de compte
une manifestation qui avait clairement
une stratégie non dite de répartition
des rôles entre des gens qui sont
violents et des gens qui sont non
violents
c'est une mise en pratique de voilà de
l'adage notamment des plus radicaux ces
dernières années qui étaient que toutes
les modes d'action se valent et
se renforce il y a quelques années ce
genre de théorie était un peu condamné
par les moins radicaux qui voyaient bien
que les émeutes ça leur nuisait d'un
point de vue médiatique mais là
manifestement on a des écolos qui
acceptent tout à fait cette logique
aujourd'hui et qui donc vont déléguer au
plus radicaux d'entre eux les actions
violentes et pour ensuite si ça marche
elle va en profiter et occuper un lieu
et si ça marche pas et ben comment ce à
quoi on assiste depuis deux jours ce
victimiser pendant des heures et des
heures en expliquant que ben non on est
gentil et c'est de la faute aux
policiers bien sûr la photos CRS si les
loutres jaunes sont venus avec des
cocktails Molotov parce que voilà comme
tout le monde le sait on peut toucher à
rente il y a des grizzly il y a des
tigres il faut bien se défendre dans la
campagne et le meilleur moyen de se
défendre contre ça c'est bien sûr les
cocktails Molotov comme tout le monde le
sait
donc voilà une une manifestation qui de
fait à mon avis a organisé ces violences
cette organisation de façon à ce que
c'est violence puisse avoir lieu et
bénéficier à tous quoi qu'il arrive soit
occupé soit pouvoir chouiner en Suisse
et je m'étonne quand même du silence
relatif du ministère de l'Intérieur sur
cette affaire parce que on a eu droit
d'armanin et toujours c'est déclarations
habituelles sur ce genre de de violence
mais là on a quand même
des violences qui étaient très
probablement programmées et on pourrait
s'attendre à un niveau de réaction de la
justice et ministère d'intérieur un
petit peu plus élevé il y a quand même
des certaines personnes à interpeller et
des collectifs à dissoudre dans le Lot
également je pense une dernière remarque
je pense que c'est violent ça pour le
coup organisée tombe un petit peu
mauvais moment parce qu'on a quand même
un mouvement social sur les retraites on
voit notamment sur la région parisienne
qui a quand même beaucoup de bavures de
la part de la police et là avec ces
images on voit quand même clairement que
ce sont les manifestants qui sont
coupables des violences à mon avis ça
risque de de brouiller la vision des
choses pour les la plupart des gens qui
sont pas politisés qui jusque là vous
pouvez peut-être prendre conscience
qu'effectivement il y a parfois la
police qui dérape et là le message est
totalement brouillé avec une séquence où
ce sont clairement la manifestants qui
ont qui ont cherché la merde donc voilà
ils sont en train de brouiller l'image
que pouvait se faire de certaines
actions de la police une partie de la
population
un moment où il aurait pas fallu
voilà bref si cette vidéo vous a
intéressé n'hésitez pas à la partager si
vous avez fait partie des manifestants
contre cette méga bassine et bien
victimisez-vous en commentaire votre
avis nous intéresse bien sûr et sur ce
je vous dis à la prochaine